do I have your permission to be
extremely direct with all of you today
yes or no all right so a few things we
need to know about today's Times
the last two messages I've given you
both times when we spoke to this
audience the market was killing it
both times when I spoke to Market was
great
when a Market's great when the economy
is great people don't listen carefully
people think they have everything
together
people are overly confident
people think it's going to last forever
people think it's going to be awesome
forever they're going to make the kind
of money forever
and then the market hits like today
and then it becomes a filtering process
the best part about what we got going on
today is the following here's the one
thing I'm most excited about we're truly
going to find out which of you were the
players the last two three four five six
seven ten years and the Market's gonna
find out who got lucky
it's very simple
the people who got lucky you're about to
be exposed
those of you that will really build on a
business on the right foundation the
Market's about to find out about you
your true leadership abilities your true
standards your right values and
principles behind closed doors you
staying disciplined you're not getting
sloppy you're not picking bad habits
you're not doing any of this dumb stuff
that hurts your business everyone's
gonna find out about you the next 6 12
24 36 months social media I've been
doing social media for about nine years
now nine years every year last night
we're having a barbecue at Glendale with
the owner of rafi's place at his house
he's making me liver and we're eating
all this food and they're talking about
how every year a new person came out in
business and social media did you hear
the new guy oh my God this guy's gonna
blow up
did you see this new guy this guy's
gonna blow up did you see this new real
estate guy this guy's gonna blow up did
you see this new person and then every
year bone what happened to that what was
his name
what was what was her name what was
their name filter filter I can give you
a lot of names right now a lot of you
guys like oh
I forgot about that person I forgot
about that person
and then you realize
to stay relevant decade after decade
after decade after decade is what's hard
to do and those who do that not only
make a lot of money but the market looks
at them as a leader so my message is a
very straight up message to you and I'm
going to give you a mindset for you to
be thinking about to know that you have
nothing to worry about while everybody
else is panicking while everybody else
has anxiety while everybody else is
losing sleep while everybody else is
stressed out while everybody else
sitting there worried about what's going
to happen you're going to sit there and
say future looks bright I have nothing
to worry about so let's get right into
the PowerPoint okay
so this right here why did I write the
long-term strategy today's message is
actually the long-term strategy why the
long-term strategy
if you've been following my content for
a while how many guys have read the book
your next five minutes raise your hand
if you've read the book your next five
tell me guys how many guys have never
read the book your next five months
you've never read it before you may want
to order the book and read it for
yourself the structure
companies that we run it's all in the
book
anybody has to ask today is who do you
want to be okay most important question
for people to ask today maybe more
important than two years ago than four
years ago then six years ago then ten
years ago it's today
for me it was simple born and raised in
Iran that's me on the left with my
sister to the right is me at 17 years
old I'm with my dad to the right of that
pictures when I joined the army I went
to the 101st Airborne Division aerosol I
had no clue what I wanted to do my life
and then I get out I start working with
Morgan Stanley Dean Witter
this picture is taken two weeks after 9
11.
while I'm working at Morgan Stanley Dean
with her
while Morgan Stanley lost 3 600
employees in their headquarters at World
Trade Center while A Man Named Dave
Kirby satistan who was the general
manager branch manager of this place in
Glendale California and he said if you
guys left the industry today I would
fully understand it it's going to be
very very hard the next two years
think about a motivational speaker
giving you a message like that and it's
your boss
he sits us down vividly he says
guys
if you chose to leave I fully get it the
next two year is going to be very hard
but I want to tell you something here
what's that if you do stick around and
you're in it after the two years
the kind of money some of you guys are
going to make none of us have ever made
before
so I sat there and I said okay I don't
know how this thing's going to be I
don't know how the Market's gonna be I
have no clue what the hell's about to
happen the meeting ends we all leave
and you know when you leave like imagine
Albert holds a meeting and then you
leave and you're sitting there talking
to yourself you're having lunch with
your guys
shall we leave
I go to the corner it's 10 of us we're
sitting there talking
I'm like so what are you going to be
doing this guy named Shaq
he was Asian but his name was Shaq which
made no sense because he was 5'4 but his
name was Shaq
so
Shaq's like guys hey
let me tell you what I want to be doing
what are you going to be doing I'm going
to go get a job at the bank because I'm
going to be the broker at the bank and
guess what they're going to do at the
bank what's that dude all you do is
nothing you just go through their
database and you just sell the existing
customers no more cold calling no more
prospecting no more this no more debt no
more this you're never going to do that
or what you're going to make 170 250
eventually three four hundred thousand
it's the best job in the world that's
what I'm going to be doing now synagogue
see what the next guy's going to say
next guy says man I I got to tell you
man I'm going to go into a completely
different industry okay what's the next
guy going to say that everybody's
talking from a place of leaving
one guy comes out and says hey Pat
all these guys whatever they said you
don't ever want to go to the bank why is
that because when you have a job that's
that's easy and you all of a sudden get
too sloppy they fire you bring somebody
else because everybody wants that job
you don't ever want to work at the bank
because they'll always fire that person
because it's an easy job you're an order
taker never take that job don't fall for
it I'm like great counsel then this guy
said this that guy said this this guy
said this I said look
I'm gonna stick around
and by the way while this whole thing is
going on I'm going through a bad breakup
the Army's asking me to come back to
wipe out my 49 000 of debt if I go back
into the army nothing's going my way in
this picture don't let the smile fool
you nothing's going good in my my way
right now okay the girl in the right I
don't know if you see that girl to the
right to the right of the light do you
see the light
in 1997 she graduated high school she
got a 1560 on her sat out of 1600.
she went to UC Berkeley got a four-year
degree in two and a half years
she also left she went and became a
scientist she makes two three hundred
thousand dollars here as a scientist
so I'm sitting there saying Pat what the
hell are you going to be doing
sat there I said you know what here's
what I've learned every book I read said
go to a place
or a market or an industry where there's
a lot of problems
be the solution be the voice be poised
be calm bring the energy to the place
you'll create a ton of wealth don't go
to the place where there's no problems
go to the place where there is problems
and become the solution
I'm like okay all these books are saying
the same thing why the hell would I
leave the industry because no industry
has more problems than the financial
industry right after 2001 911. like you
know what I'm sticking around so I stick
around
I stick around I get my whole licenses
everything I double down I get my
insurance license
I go to trans
world I stay with them for seven and a
half years do incredibly well for myself
October of all night we start our own
insurance company and we grow the
insurance company from 66 agents we've
licensed now 35 000 agents we have 20
000 active agents few hundred offices
Nationwide
and we stay focused part-time I'm
creating content 2012 2013 I do my first
video I did one video a week two minutes
with Pat
and I said I'm gonna do a hundred videos
for two years
if the audience doesn't like the way I
give my message I will shut it down I'll
never create content again but I'm going
to do one video a week on a phone
two minutes with Pat like this and I'll
try it once a week
we did a hundred videos every single
video was over two minutes typically 12
15 minutes the only video that was ever
two minutes was the last video the
biggest complaint I got is Pat you can't
say two minutes with Pat you're lying to
all of us you got to say 10 minutes with
that 15 minutes with that none of them
are two minutes
two years later we changed our strategy
for content
next thing you know the content works on
what it's doing then we get a hundred
thousand Subs half a million Subs a
million subs today we got I don't know
four and a half five million Subs we got
like 10 YouTube channels a few hundred
thousand few Channels with 300 000 Subs
Russian language Spanish language we're
launching Arabic Mandarin a whole
different thing that we're doing with
that business that grew 90 days ago
the insurance company we partner with a
new company called IMG money came from
uh Silver Lake money
we sold a business for a very very very
nice
multi-multi nine-figure type of
evaluation
and we had a nice 83 percent give or
take equity in the company
why am I sharing the story with you
when I'm here I'm broke
this was my vision I wanted to one day
have this
I told my family I told myself when I
was 23 24 years old
relationship didn't work out I said
listen long term Pat not short term long
term what life do you want
I sat there I said long term
these Americans eventually if you have
kids these Americans like to do these uh
what do you do when the kids get
together and they spend the night at
someone's house what do they call that
stuff what do you call it
I don't like sleepovers
I'm from Iran guys we don't do
sleepovers but if you are gonna do
sleepovers you're going to do it at our
house with 40 cameras around it's the
only place you're doing a sleepover at
well now my kids are not doing a
sleepover at your place you can come to
my place okay
then I said one day when I'm a
grandfather and we have our kids that
marry other people
their kids our grandkids are gonna
decide which grandpa's house and
Grandma's house they want to go for
Christmas and Thanksgiving
we have to offer the best place
what do you mean we got out for the best
place I want the in-laws to stay I want
their kids to stay bring your grandkids
if it's 40 I'm gonna get a house big
enough for 40 50 people stay in one
place
why you want to do that by the way I'm
saying this at 24 years old I'm only 43
right now I'm thinking at 65 70 years
old whose house Jennifer an idea that
they are looking at a house we want to
buy in uh babe are you in the audience
are you in the back I don't know what
she's at maybe she's in the back okay
we're looking at a house the other day
in Greenwich you guys know where
Greenwich is at you know on the
Connecticut area the house we're looking
at is 12 acres it's 20 something 25 000
square foot house 40 million dollar
house and we want to buy this place
because we want to have a place where
the family can go and I'm going to
create the podcast set where we do
podcasts from their kids play their
summer you stay there 60 days 90 days we
do business back and forth we open up a
business office or I can do business
from there while we're staying out of
Greenwich house guys I've been thinking
about this life
20 years
20 years
and the reason why I'm sharing this with
you at this time
because so many people are currently
worried about short-term issues
interest rates fed Russia Ukraine all of
this methods it's true it is a very very
scary time but if you're thinking long
term it's not a scary time it's a
regular Tuesday when you're thinking
long term does that make sense to
everybody so now this is what I'm saying
to you long term what life do you want
to have
we got four kids now
Brooklyn's at the top
she is extremely smart you know how I
know that
her first words were Daddy
and she loves me the most brilliant kid
this kid knows what she's doing
we got Senna that's right next to mommy
she has no clue who I am
she sees me as the person that just
makes the money of course she loves me
but she's in love with Mommy right
Fireball
Dylan is the one in the pink Patrick is
one in a blue
four days ago I'm at the house I'm like
guys you know one of you guys going to
be a president one day
and they're like Dylan's like it's not
going to be me I said I didn't say it's
going to be you
I said one of you it could be Brooklyn
it could be Senna it could be Tico it
could be you but one of you is going to
be a president one day by the way what's
the chances of one of my kids being a
president one day you know what the
chances point zero zero zero one if you
actually do the percentage how slim is
it it's a very small number so I tell
them that
and I notice he's like it's not going to
be me it's going to be one of them three
I'm like okay let's see if he's gonna
bite three minutes later you know what
question he asked me
he says
hey Daddy I got a question for you
what's that
how old do you have to be to be a
president
it's a buying question that's all I want
I said 35 you got a long ways to go
we're not going to talk about later on
but one of you guys will be president
one day what's the point here
I have no idea if any of this stuff's
going to become a reality or not none of
this stuff I have no idea but I'm
casting a vision and I'm thinking long
term when you have a vision long term
that you're excited about current issues
don't stress you out
they don't every one of your competitors
many of them that are not going to make
it the next two years I can guarantee
you right now ninety percent of them out
there thinking about is today
that's all I'm going to tell you I
guarantee you because I had a lot of
guys I went up against in the last 20
something years that were bigger than me
smarter than me better degrees better
markets better background better
accolades better speakers better
everything they look better they look
like somebody that would be a silver
insurance company do I look like a CEO
of an insurance company I look like a
bodyguard from the Middle East I don't
look like a Sylvan Insurance Company
the typical insurance agent was a 56
year old white male I asked the guy said
what percentage of insurance agents are
from Iran because like what are you
talking about
I said out of all these agents we have
in America what percentage are Iranian I
said no listen Pat you guys are in the
other section there's white then it's
Asian then it's Hispanic then it's black
then it's this then it's that you're in
the other section less than one percent
I'm not supposed to be here that's what
I'm trying to tell you okay but again
long term is the way to think today in
this economy so now
outcome I want to give you some
perspective and some mindset so now
a few data points 53 of Americans say
they rarely or never think about far
future
53 never think about it
some of you are saying 20 years
I'm not going to be thinking 20 years
ahead I'm going to think maybe three
weeks ahead but not 20 years ahead I get
it it's not easy to do
21 report image imagining this future
less than once a year can you imagine
that means one out of five person
even sits there thinking about the
future
it's like all I'm going to be thinking
about is right one out of five so if
you're on the other side you already
have an edge over these guys 32 say
never even crosses their mind at all
this is why I asked the question for you
about long-term versus short-term
planning everything's about the question
who do you want to be a recent study
revealed that around 33 of small
businesses have a formal business plan
how many of you right now if I called on
you and I said I got a hundred thousand
dollars I'm going to give away right now
who has their formal business plan with
them in their hands right now raise your
hand if you have it with you
raise the end if you have it with you
I'll give you a hundred thousand dollars
stand up if you have it with you stand
up if you have it with you okay here's
another question for you how many of you
guys how many guys your business plan
that you wrote for the year you've read
it or looked at it in the last week
be honest straight up you spent a few
thousand dollars to come here so we
don't need in the last week how many
guys looked at your business plan look
around actually look don't look at me
look around
look around do you by the way some when
people used to do that with me in an
audience I still be like man he's making
me feel like [ __ ] right now stop the
point the point is you just found an
edge here because no one's doing that
everyone's just winging it
your entire competition ninety percent
they're all winging it
and most likely you and I are also
winging it but the Market's wide open
today especially today but no one's
planning so now
the greatest danger this is one of the
greatest Business Consultants and
authors of all time go by every one of
them you'll never be disappointed Peter
Drucker he said the greatest Danger
in times of turbulence is not the
turbulence
it is to act with yet act with
yesterday's logic you know what this
means I'm going to solve it the same way
I solved it five years ago it's not
going to work today
it's a different problem today yeah I'm
gonna do it the same way I did it 10
years ago it's not going to work today
let me give you some more perspective
like I said I was going to give it to
you Dow Jones
anyone know where Dow Jones was on
Friday where did Dow Jones end up with
on Friday anyone knows
what did thou end up on Friday
28 something right and just a few months
ago that was at what 36 7 36 9.
so first time exactly
markets dropped from 37 000 to 28.5 on
Friday I think the market dropped five
six hundred points is what a drop okay
now here's the thing people panic
people panic on what's going on with the
market
this is the Dow in 1957.
did you hear what I just said 1957
Dallas at 435
this is now in 1970 838
this is now 1983. this is only 39 years
ago guys how many guys are older than 39
raise than if you're older than 39.
you've lived longer than 30 down 39
years ago was only at 12 58.
that was at 29 right now
it's 22.8 times since 39 years ago
1996 it was 6400.
you're at graduate high school
2009 10 000 428
2022 as of Friday 28 725
so if we go back and look at what the
Market's done from what was the number
from four something to what
from 4 35 all the way up to
28 000. when you look at this how do you
feel when you hear these numbers when
you look at this how do you feel right
now like what are you thinking about
what does it make you think about
that means long term guess what what's
going to happen long term
we're okay long term now watch this
housing markets rates how many of you
love
the rates go from 2.8 just a year ago
to what is it now 683 okay 685 wherever
how many guys love the rates increasing
the way they are
this is raked in 1957. five and a
quarter
1970 eight and a half
1983 3.2 how many guys will like a 3.2
anybody would like a 3.2 you know what
it was in 1981
6.
let me say one more time in 1981
interest rates were 15 to 16 percent and
in two years it went down to 3.2
1995 1996 7.8
2009 5.04 today 6.83
what's the most constant thing that we
notice about the race the last since
1950s what do you notice
always changes okay but even though the
rates are changing let me show you the
next part
average price of a home 1957 19 Grand
1970 25 Grand
1983 64 Grand
1996 100 112 000 2009 188 thousand
dollars 2022
388 thousand dollars what do you notice
throughout the entire time
it never was less
it kept going up
again the mindset of what
long-term thinking you're fine
short term you'll Panic long term you
walk around the room like this hey
Johnny how are you good
you're good Patrick everything good
everything's good man I'm excited bro
you are excited very excited very
hey Larry how are you all right
I don't know man my wife and I had a bad
fight last night how are you everything
good future looks bright and I'm super
excited about the future super excited
about hey Jackie everything good oh did
you hear is today the day that they
already announced the rates I don't know
but guess what what future looks so
bright now I'm so excited about the
future
and eventually everyone's going to get
together you know what they're going to
say I really think that's on ecstasy
today
I saw him drinking a lot of water
and his wife was rubbing his back
something's going on with this guy he's
rolling I'm telling you past too happy
today but no you're thinking what
long term while everybody else is
thinking what five minutes
let me continue does anybody know who
this guy is
who is this guy come on it ain't me for
sure cause I'm not white but who is this
guy
who
Warren Buffett it is good for you
this is Warren Buffett that's his net
worth in 1957.
how many guys have more money than 140
000 reason if you got more than 140 000
net worth okay you're richer than Warren
Buffett once was
now watch this we're about to dissect
this and then you'll see where I'm going
with this and I'm going to give you a
clear leaks some of you are making and
to make sure you plug it so it doesn't
get worse for you and you Excel and one
day we're telling your story on stage
like this
1957
he's worth 140. 13 years later
1970.
he's worth 25 million
what do you want to be worth in 13 years
huh
long term you want to think that long
too long right oh 13 years
you ready for the next one the next
one's intense by the way
from 1970 to 1983 what do you think is
net worth is in 83.
620.
from 6 20 to 1996 you ready
boom
17 billion
2009
37 billion
2022.
97 billion
from 140 000 dollars
200 billion dollar net worth why though
why what do you think separates him from
his peers
I'm reading uh they write this book down
guys everybody needs to go write this
book I don't write it's a book called
the uh how to invest by a guy named
David Rubinstein that's worth four
billion dollars okay he's the guy that
started a company called Carlisle Group
you've probably heard of Carlisle group
he goes in interviewing all of these
billionaires and guys that are running
hedge funds and ask them what is your
investment strategy right do you know 90
of all the people you'll see when you
read this I'd say 70 of all the people
they Enter he interviewed everybody
gives credit to one person guess who it
is
this guy guess what they say about him
his Edge on everybody was what he said
what
and everybody else is thinking what
my return this year is like no man we're
going to go long term do you guys know a
year and a half ago what they were
bashing uh Buffett for
uh Warren Buffett sitting on 125 billion
dollars of cash with Berkshire Hathaway
we feel Warren buff has lost his ways
you know he is no longer the same Warren
Buffett he once used to be the last
seven years he's been losing to SMP you
are better off to put the money in the S
P 500 or Bitcoin or ethereum rather than
putting the money with Berkshire
Hathaway
how many guys would love to have 125
billion dollars of cash today
what do you think he's about to buy
he's going shopping
and guess what he's buying the next
three six 12 months companies on
Flipping sale
and the next thing you know boom Next
Level now
the guy is not going to live another 26
years to see a couple more doubles I
think he's 90 years old right now but
the point is this what if what if many
of us think like he does
what if many of us think like he does
so again those who capitalize from the
current times will be let me tell you
we'll be long-term thinkers
will be long-term thinkers
here lies a short-term thinker
over the next three six 12 months I'm
telling you right now go to the cemetery
of former money makers filled with
short-term thinkers everywhere
when I study for my series seven I
studied for my series seven every day
next to my grandmother's plot at Forest
Lawn right after 17134 freeway I don't
know if you guys know where that's at
and I would sit right next to her and I
would read my Capital look to take my
series seven because she had just died
so I would study there it was calming
for me
when I would take a break I would walk
and this was my exercise
yeah I don't recognize that name
nope
39 years this person lived
62 years
83 years
49 years and you would stand like this
who was this guy and then there was like
one big one you see this name and he'd
go Google it oh wow this guy was
somebody
okay crazy boom
and I would sit down and say okay when
the day comes and you die what are you
going to say when they walk by your plot
here lies a short-term thinker hell to
the no
how many guys want to say that with me
on three one two three
[Applause]
say it with me say I'm a long-term
thinker
say it again
say it louder
even louder
last time
don't say it to yourself regularly
if your wife is upset say babe remember
babe we're what what babe we're
long-term thinkers we are long-term
thinkers you're gonna see stress is
going to go like this confidence is
going to go like this
Poise is going to go here
so now let's look at the whole thing
together because I want to make a point
to you guys I want to make a point to
you guys
everything I just showed you this is a
snapshot
they have on one page
it shows thou where it was to where it's
at today
interest rates how many times it changed
home price value how many times it
changed but this is the one I want to
show you
look at the amount of times Warren
Buffett
increased his net worth and how many
doubles it was look at this
from 40 from 140 foul to 25 million you
know what that is that's 178 X
178 X
the next one is 25x from 25 million to
620.
how many guys would like to increase
your net worth 25x the next 13 years
would anybody like that
that's exactly the point
so now next one
27x from 620 to 17 billion then it's 2.2
x
then it's 2.68 the guy was struggling at
the end he only went from 37 billion to
100 billion poor guy if you guys want to
send him some money you can sell them
five bucks I'm sure he'll appreciate if
you send him some money
but he started with 140.
what's the number you're starting off
with so what's the difference between
this guy and you well Pat you can't
compare me to Buffett I get it I'm not
telling you for you to be worth 100
billion dollars however many years from
now but can you think long term to say
40 years from now I want to be worth 100
million is that realistic of course it
is why can't you put 100 million dollar
number to yourself
why can't you say hey you know what babe
I don't know in 13 years I want to be
worth 10 million
let's solve for 10 million in 13 years I
know it's a lot of money to us today
when we got 52 000 but if this guy can
go from 52 to 20 from 140 to 125 I want
to go 52 to 10 million in 13 years great
then go solve for that
and it gives you something to look
forward to and it's exciting when you're
thinking that way
next one
as we go through this okay
as we go through this
I want to show you this
if thou from 1983
went from 1258 to 28 000 how many times
is that
does anybody how many times that is that
is 23x
let's take 23x and see where Dao will be
from today by 2061. many of you will be
alive in 2061. believe it or not we're
living a long life nowadays
here's what it looks like
that was going to be at 655 902.
you know what this means long-term
future looks what
short term future short term times look
what maybe scary but not long term so
now in order for this to work for you
you need a clear Philosophy for this to
happen who knows the story of Anne
Mulcahy who knows who and Mulkey he is
does anybody know who animal K he is
raise your hand if you know who she is
does anyone know who she is I love the
fact that you don't know who she is but
you're going to know in a minute when I
tell you her story
but before I tell you a story
we have to know for some of you guys
your business is growing during good
good or bad times you have to study it
but many times when the business isn't
growing we don't like to study to see
what things we could have done
differently
two weeks ago I got a hold of a book
called How to Mighty Pho uh how to
Mighty Fall if you guys haven't ordered
this book yet it's an easy book it's
four hours the audible just ordered
ordered the audible and listen to it
it's worth reading anybody's read the
book good to Great who's read the book
good to great it's the same author that
wrote good to great so if you don't know
the book it's good to Great Jim Collins
is a legend
how to Mighty Fall there's five things
this author talks about on how to Mighty
Fall five things here's what the five
things are
number one
hubris born of success does anybody know
what this means
hubris born of success means what
full of yourself when you start making
money and you start saying I'm so good
I am so amazing
we did it because we're smarter than
everybody else nobody is as good as we
are and then you start saying wow you
know the people it was really all me it
wasn't anybody else I did all of this it
was all me this is because of me all
because of me
and that's a very unattractive quality
when a person gets to this point
the author asks two questions it's a
very interesting question I want your
attention with these two questions
because it has a lot to do with step
number one phase number one he talks
about
he says you have two options on who to
be
two options option number one is to be
the person that says the following we're
winning because we're great
we're the best no one's like us what are
the best at what we do we're smarter
than everybody we work harder than
everybody we're this we're that we have
the best technology we have the bestest
we have the best dad
that's one mindset the second mindset he
says
is when you say look guys we're good
but man I really think we have to
improve our technology or else
guys I think we're solid we have a very
good thing going on here in this system
but I think the other guy's doing it
better I do think we need to improve our
systems a little bit and tighten it up
guys I do think we have that client that
we just closed that's a million dollar
commission but I'm just gonna go stop by
and visit them today in case another
person came and tried to sell them away
from us today I'm gonna go stop by
because I don't know if we 100 have them
I think we have declined 80 but I'm not
convinced we have them 100 percent
guys I think those two sales people that
work for us the two loss I think they're
happy but I'm going to take them to a
restaurant tonight just to make sure
they're happy because I don't I I think
they're locked in but I'm going to take
them out to dinner tonight you got two
mindsets one of them is what
we're the best the other one is what
we're good but I think we got to kind of
I still think we got work to do right
the author says a person who thinks like
this if you are right and you're the
best guess what you kill everybody as a
competitor
but if you're wrong what happens
you're going out of business
then he comes over here and it says this
mindset the person's like I just think
we're not there yet guys I think we got
to do this we're good but I think we got
to improve this we got to call the
client one more time this mindset he
says
if you're right
that's great
if you're wrong that's great
did you get the question on what he's
saying both ways you're better off
betting here a lot of people in the
marketplace were here the last one two
three four five ten years we're the best
we're the best we're the best hubris
born of success you think it's because
of you and you cannot lose number two
undisciplined Pursuit
of more it's very interesting how we
explain this here
how many guys remembered a company
called Rubbermaid who remembers
Rubbermaid anybody remembers Rubbermaid
so one day Rubbermaid is killing it
they're doing great they're dominating
the marketplace
they all of a sudden say the way we're
going to beat everybody
is we're going to produce and invent one
new product every day for the next three
years
oh my God that's so innovative
every day for three years they produce a
new product
guess what happens three years later
they have a thousand new products but
guess what happened to their company
they don't know how to sell it because
they want 2y too soon they lost their
specialty they lost their focus boom
they took a massive hit the market came
and passed them up during the time like
this a lot of people during scary times
like the one we're in they're gonna try
to say okay let me tell you what we
offer and we offer this and we do credit
repair and we do REO and we do short
sale and we do a loan modification and
we do that and we do this and we do them
we offer this and we offer that they're
gonna we offer 48 different products not
the right strategy
you're going here you're being tempted
to try to do everybody like you're going
to come to a meeting like this oh we're
going to sell this oh no no let's do
this over here no let's do this no let's
do this let's do this let's do that
momentum's not going to be created every
time you're shifting and adjusting your
philosophies not strategic number three
number three is denial risk and peril
here's what this is
how many of you guys we've all done this
before but tell me if you relate to this
how many guys look at your data on a
weekly basis you look some kind of data
on a weekly basis if not on a monthly
basis raise in if you look at some data
how many guys sometimes
when you're talking to your team
or yourself you only want to look at the
data that makes you look good how many
guys have done that but reason if you've
done that before right we've all done it
before right okay
it'll be like this in a meeting so oh
guys let me tell you what happened do
you know we have a record-breaking
amount of 1003s the applications that
came in and the amount of calls that we
show it's amazing
yeah but we're not fun we're we have we
have to look no no no no let's stay
positive do you realize what's going on
you know how much money we're making
look how much money we're I get it but
customers we're getting 22 percent fewer
customers coming into the restaurant
every day stop being negative do you
realize what we did we have now expanded
open up five more new offices
yeah I know but dude our our ebitda just
dropped what are we doing our ebitda
just dropped Michael burry who knows who
Michael burry is does anybody know who
Michael burry is how many guys have no
clue Michael berrias the moment I tell
you who he is you know who he is you're
going to follow him on Twitter who's
seen the movie Big Short
the guy who predicted it his name is
Michael burry he has an account on
Twitter it's called Cassandra it's him
he's got like six 800 000 followers go
follow him he tweeted something two days
ago he said the following
how many guys know what the word ebitda
is does anybody know what the word
ebitda means he says how is it that we
have a hundred companies on the market
right now that are worth 10 billion
dollars but their ebitda was minus 100
million dollars the last 12 months
did anybody catch what I just said right
now companies worth 10 billion dollars
but their net profits minus 100 million
he's like is anybody looking at this
stuff this is the same thing he said
with big short
so this is where people are like no no
but don't look at all the data what
you're supposed to do in this session
here is you're supposed to sit with your
leaders at guys listen
we have to look at these numbers
together because you first sell
everybody on what the vision is long
term not short term
if division is long-term we have to look
at all this data he said the reason why
the Mighty Fall is they do not look at
the data that doesn't make them happy
they don't have the guts to do it number
four let's go to number four
number four is
um
grasping for salvation you know what
stage this is
this is where you're now begging
this is when you all of a sudden you go
to Walmart
you buy a set of knee pads because never
in your life have you prayed this many
times before you're getting on your
knees you you've started praying to to
Prophet Muhammad you're you're praying
to to Jesus you're praying to Abraham
you're praying to every religion you go
from Catholic to Mormonism to
Scientology you're like any God that's
listening to me can one of you guys make
a miracle for me please
you're now begging for salvation
please save me please save us
and what happens next
capitulation to irrelevance or death
do you know what that means
a little bit too many big words for me
as well
does anybody know what capitulation to
irrelevance or death you know what that
means you're gone you're out of business
so now
how many guys are willing to admit to
the following
raise your hand if you're willing to say
I think we went through a little bit of
stage number one how many of you guys
went through a little bit of stage
number one which is kind of like man I
think we're like really really good and
you're like I don't know if we're as
good as we okay by the way all of us are
there all of us are there how many guys
are currently maybe at stage number two
you're like trying a million different
things to try to get so Innovative how
many guys are at stage number three
right now you're like you do not want to
look at the bad numbers you do not want
to look at the bad numbers whatever
stage you're at I'm gonna go back and
tell you the story of animal kahi here's
what animal kahi said animal okay he
started working at Xerox in 1976 as a
salesperson
24 years later Anne Mulcahy who did
sales for 16 years and for eight years
she did HR and home office the board
makes a decision
to promote and Mulcahy from a Xerox
salesperson
do you know what position
what position do you think they gave her
from a salesperson
a company the size of Xerox do you want
to take a while guess what the position
was you can scream it out what do you
think it was
to the CEO of Xerox what
so she gets the call the board says yup
and
we're announcing as the next CEO of
Xerox you're announcing me as a Knicks
yep you're the next CEO of Xerox oh but
I'm not ready they're announcing it as a
Xerox
okay she's a CEO but we got some news
for you what's that let us tell you what
kind of company you're getting what's
that I'm ready for this this is exciting
I'm gonna become the CEO of Xerox this
is at a time where women are not
becoming CEOs of Fortune 100 companies
this isn't today this is years ago in
2001 August 15th is when she got the
promotional CEO with Xerox
they said here's where the company's at
today
Xerox today we are in debt
debt bonds
we're in debt 19 billion dollars
and she's like okay but how much cash do
we have
we're in debt 19 billion dollars we only
have a hundred million dollars in a bank
account
let me give you some perspective that's
like you have a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars in credit card and you
only have a thousand dollars in a bank
how many of you guys would be freaking
out right now if that was you and you
got that job that's how she got promoted
to CEO
so she sits there
she's looking at the saying this year
the board tells her we lost 376 million
dollars this year
Moody's does anybody know what Moody's
Grading Company is they graded Xerox
Xerox bonds as junk bonds does anyone
know what a junk bond is like it's trash
don't waste your time don't buy the
bonds of Xerox now how many here know
who Xerox is who knows who Xerox is who
knows who Xerox is how many guys have
bought a product from Xerox before in
your office this is Xerox we're talking
about Xerox about to go out of business
and location salesperson 26 she's been
with them from 1976 she's a salesperson
day promoter 16 years she's been doing
sales she's now the CEO
they have for the first meeting
she gets up and she says
let me tell you guys the story of Xerox
here's who we are here's what we've
overcome here's what we've done here's
why we've won here's what we've done
well here's what we're going to go back
to we're not going through 50 new
products we're not going back to doing
all this stuff we're going to shut this
down it's wasting money we're going to
shut that down we're going to close this
down we're going to go to basic
fundamentals and she went out there
started talking to all of the executive
the employees the sales people lifting
everybody up hey thank you for your work
you're doing such a great job let's keep
getting better thank you for your work
you're doing such a great job let's keep
getting better she kept going to
everybody talking talking talking
talking
two years later or so
they profit a billion dollars four years
later chief executive magazine calls her
the CEO of the Year Forbes
said she is the sixth most powerful
woman in the world
and Mulcahy and she started off as a
regular sales rep for Xerox
what's the point here
what your family right now needs what my
family right now needs what our family
right now needs our company our
Associates people were working with it's
going back to the basic fundamentals the
future looks bright long term we're good
let me tell you why we started this
company here's why we started XYZ this
is what the vision was these are our
customers how can we help you look some
of you are not going to be here with us
long term I know times are going to be
hard but those of you that do one day
we're going to tell the story we had one
of our guys
in 2010 these guys got started with us
okay they came with us they were with us
for two years when I gave the first
round of equity to our sales guys they
qualify for the second biggest share
when they got this equity
when times got hard they stepped away
year later this is 2012 2013 they
stepped away
when this event took place a few months
ago you know directly you know how much
your exit was supposed to be if I tell
you the number you'd be you'd feel so
bad for those guys
you would feel so bad for them but I
told everybody
listen
times are not going to be always good
we're going to go through some
challenging times it's going to be hard
those of you who stick around with us
long term were going to take over the
world together and this was the constant
language so now Pat what do I do from
here a few things for you to be thinking
about number one you got to initiate new
contact you have to be a Biz Dev machine
today network card network card network
card
send them a gift send them a book be
different when you network with people
don't just go and network and get
people's numbers and try to do business
with them they want become an incredible
networker number two maintain the
current contacts that you have and then
Advance the current contacts that you
have what does that mean maintaining
just hey Johnny how's everything family
is good everybody's good yes fantastic
Johnny how can I help you what are you
going through right now that I can help
you with oh we're good man everything
well you know what I am looking for
somebody that's a great CPA do you know
great accountant Absolutely I'll give
you two options on great accountants I'm
gonna text them to you right a matter of
fact did you get the text yes these are
the two best guys give them a call I'll
call them and let them know that he
should be expecting a call from him hey
thank you so much Patrick no problem by
the way can I ask you a question yeah
I'm looking for a couple people here to
help raise money do you know any good
investment bankers I should be talking
to of course I got one his name is
Jackie fantastic can I get his name in
do you mind sending an email or group
text and make an intro most definitely
because I'm initiating new contacts I'm
maintaining my existing contact and I'm
advancing my existing contact to meet
people that they know this is what you
got to be doing the next three six
twelve months but by the way how many of
us in this room can do a much better job
as a at a basic fundamental skill set as
this how many of us can get better at
this the next six 12 months who in this
room all of us can get better at this
all of us can get better at this now
here's the next one
the next one I'll wrap up with that I
want you to be thinking about
we just recently signed to a launch the
next book with a penguin that we're
doing a book with
and we're sitting there we're talking
about everything that we're going to be
doing
two Sundays ago we're at the house and
I'm sitting there saying Mario's asking
questions we're going back and forth
it's like so you know how do you do
leadership development how do you
improve yourself how do you increase the
value in the marketplace what do we do
with some of our guys what do you do to
get your people to be better and
yourself to get better and we wrote out
and we came out with this Paradigm Shift
quadrant let me share this with you
there's four areas
that you and I can improve ourselves to
increase our market value
two of them you do doesn't explode your
market value two above that you do
explodes your market value you and the
people that work with you let me share
this with you bottom left is hard skills
does anybody here have a hard skill that
pays very well raise your hand if you
have a good hard skill matter of fact on
three scream out the hard skill that
you're very good at one two three
that's a hard skill okay
so first one is hard skills you'll learn
how to get a hard skills if you learn
hard skills you pretty much have a nice
salary for yourself but it's not enough
so what's the next one Pat I said
character
what's character character doesn't mean
stealing cheating any of that stuff
character to me is somebody that shows
up somebody that's doing the work
somebody if they say they're going to do
something they do with somebody that
follows up somebody that doesn't cancel
appointments if we got a five o'clock
appointment all of a sudden somebody
invites you to a Laker game you don't
cancel the appointment go to a Lakers
game and reschedule it there's a lot of
sales people that will always reschedule
appointments the moment something else
comes up I don't like that kind of stuff
you got a four o'clock appointment keep
your four o'clock appointment unless if
a massive crisis happens and less than
one percent of your appointment you
should reschedule or cancel let me say
that one more time less than one percent
of your appointments you should ever
reschedule and cancel this guy keeps all
of his appointments he shows up on time
clients are very happy
if you do those two things is that
enough
are those two things alone to increase
your market value today
the answer is no because those two just
make you a good citizen
and every company every Community every
society needs good citizens but it's not
enough there's two of them that we got
to go through here soft skills today
is very very valuable a lot of people
are not that good at soft skills a lot
of people know how to do real estate
maybe they know how to sell but they're
not that good with people they know how
to do insurance annuities 401ks but
they're not that good with people soft
skill is known how to talk to a person
that's a customer that's married
during their 60s you talk to somebody
that's widowed divorced white black
Hispanic Asian degree no degree makes
six figures as low income middle income
very wealthy very well off affluent soft
skills allows that person to be able to
work with everyone you increase your
market value if you got good soft skills
and then the last one is a paradigm
shift
almost everybody in this room if you
ever suddenly recreated yourself and you
were a new person that your family
friends had never seen before you had a
paradigm shift you had a paradigm shift
it could have been with your family it
could have been with your friends it
could have been with something but let
me explain what a paradigm shift is
paradigm shift is some of you guys are
here is this day one or is this day two
of the event this is day two
they wanted the event okay
who today out of all the speakers not
myself the people Prime me who today
said something to you that got you
really thinking all day today
how many guys saw something somebody
said that you've been thinking about it
all day today
okay so what was it somebody tell me
what it was what was the one thing
somebody told you that got you thinking
all day today
mental toughness what else is it
execute what else
operations and systems what else
say that again
long term what else
total Recreation okay let me give you
some Paradigm shifts for me
I'm in the Army
I'm about to re-enlist for six years
it's June of 1999. everything I asked
for my sergeant they brought for me my
Colonel they gave to me I'm going to
Vicenza Italy
I'm going to go be a special forces 18
Delta they gave me everything I spoke
four languages five languages German was
good but it wasn't good enough to be
counted as a fifth I was gonna go to DLI
I was going to go to the chance I was
going to get everything
I'm in bed at 11 45 I get a call from a
guy I had barbecued last night guy's
name is Colgan he calls me says hey Pat
how's everything I said great I'm about
to re-enlist for six more years they got
me everything I wanted he says what do
you mean I said I'm about to stay in the
Army for six more years he says you
can't do that I said what do you mean I
can't do that I'm doing that I'm doing
it tomorrow you can't do that
I said I'm doing it tomorrow like I
can't do anything about I already told
my dad I'm re-enlisting tomorrow it's my
ceremony I'm getting an army
accommodation medal and I'm gone Pat you
can't do it give me one hour to convince
you not to do it I'm like you're not
going to do it one hour on the phone
the things he told me
he shook me
I couldn't believe what he was telling
me by the time we were done I couldn't
sleep all night I woke up I couldn't
even sleep I got up in the morning I
went to Lieutenant Colonel peacocks
I said Colonel peacocks I got to tell
you something he says what's that
I said I can't re-enlist
he says what do you mean he said I gotta
go into civilian I got to go be a
civilian I think I can make it as a
civilian but David you're going to be an
incredible Soldier for us I can't
reenlist I have to get out I got a phone
call I'm so sorry because you changed my
life I got to get out I can't reenlist
they pull my Army accommodation medal I
get out of the army that phone call was
a paradigm shift because the guy made a
phone call and believed in me at my low
like I'm like me I'm a regular army guy
1.8 GPA who was in the military here
before Make Some Noise if you were in
the military before okay let's make some
noise for these guys by the way what was
your what was your ASVAB score scream
out your ASVAB score on three one two
three
I I got a 31.
the only job I could be is infantry or a
Hummer mechanic guess what I chose
Hummer mechanic
I'm a regular guy I'm supposed to do 20
years in the military
that phone call shook me couldn't sleep
I had a paradigm shift I got out my life
changed
one day I'm at a Christmas party with my
family my dad and I a Syrian Christmas
party I'm 25 26 years old
we're talking to everybody we're poor
we're not doing well
and one of the guys on my dad changed
his life the guy makes a comment to my
my dad offends my dad
I listened to him I'm like
dad what did he just say to you he said
this he can't talk to you like that I
said Patrick these are my friends you
can't say anything I said no we're
leaving we're not staying here right now
we got to get out of here I said no no
we're not leaving it's a Christmas party
they invited I said that way you don't
talk to my dad like this I said listen I
love you your family I love you a lot
but you don't talk like that it's just a
joke it's not a joke I like
it's not a joke I like that we're
leaving I'm not leaving with you I'm
your I'm your right what are you talking
let's go but we gotta well I'm not
leaving with you what's the matter I
said we're leaving Dad we're leaving
we get in the car Ford Focus is what I'm
I'm six five I don't fit on the Ford
Focus I'm driving a Ford Focus
do you know 30 minute drive from
Glendale to Granada Hills were fighting
the entire time
we're fighting I'm like I allowed
another man to disrespect my dad in
front of me and I'm not
guys that small little
75 second interaction is why I told my
entire family the World's Gonna know my
dad's last name
I said dad they're gonna have to kill
this guy they're gonna know your last
name
they're going to know your last name how
much you did for all of these freaking
people in your family they're gonna know
your last name they're gonna have to
kill me they're gonna know your last
name what are you saying we're regular
people what is the matter with you why
are you saying that I understand but
they're going to know who you are and
how many people's lives you change your
son's gonna show the world what you're
all about you'll see I call my family my
sister and my brother-in-law coming out
guys I don't I don't talk like this I
had a paradigm shift
I went to sales meetings this is is this
Long Beach Convention Center 20 years
ago I went to a Tony Robbins seminar
here I was 21 years old
these are Paradigm Shift type of moments
but you have to receive it when this
thing ends at 7 30 tonight I don't know
what plans everybody got I'll tell you
what I'd be doing if I was at a place
like this especially with the [ __ ] show
of a market we got going on right now
I'm not going to about drinking
I'm gonna go get cards and network do
all that stuff boom straight away from
everybody business planning pen paper
let's go for hours
I'm gonna have a paradigm shift type of
a moment at this event I'm gonna change
my life what hard skills do I need what
character do I need to improve as a
human being what soft skills do I need
what do I need to do I'm going to do
something special in my life that's the
decision you got to be making FYI less
than five percent of you will do what I
just said
less than five percent of you will do
what I just said most of you are looking
forward to partying tonight
I went to an insurance conference one of
the main Executives says Pat why don't
you ever drink with everybody I said
drink for what
he says but you always have a drink but
you start with the same drink and at the
end of the night it's the same drink
with the same amount left
I said first I want to make everybody
feel comfortable I have a drink but I'm
not drinking why don't you drink
because if I drink I'm loose I'm no
longer learning I'm talking
If I Stay still they're talking I'm
learning why would I drink
he says I never thought about it that
way before
you guys got to make a decision these
numbers I'm telling you these people are
not any more special than you they made
a flipping decision a long time ago
it made a very major decision a long
time ago and today your family your
peers people around you are relying on
you I went to this protesting right
before I'm going 120 miles an hour on
the freeway with people in the car
I want to run the Iranian Community I
don't like what's going on anymore it
bothers me I was born in Iran I'm made
in America I'm half Armenian half a
Syrian and I love America but I love
Iran
I got four kids I want to one day take
them there and show them these places
these things matter to me
you have to think about your heritage
you have to think about the sacrifices
your mom your dad made to bring you to
America you you owe it to them on what
they did for you
that has to get you to be thinking about
your dreams in a completely different
way this ain't about a Lambo and a
Ferrari and a Rolls-Royce and a 25
million dollar house this ain't about
that
this about today the world is looking
for leaders and what are you going to do
about it
that's what today's all about
so now these two things bottom one
reliable citizen I'm willing to bet a
hundred percent of your reliable
citizens you're good for Marketplace
you pay your bills you pay your taxes
you take care of your family I'm willing
to bet 99 of you guys are good citizens
or else you wouldn't be at an event like
this
the one above is impactful citizen it is
time for us to make a decision to become
an impactful citizen not just a reliable
citizen this is the part about a
paradigm shift I told you right up front
I was going to be straight up with you
you can have plenty of motivational
speakers it's not my style I'm going to
give it to you raw you'll like it great
you don't like it it's not my problem
you got to do something with this that's
how I like to be spoken to
I want somebody to tell me exactly what
the hell is going on and what do I need
to know and what do I need to do about
it that's all I want to hear from you
that's the message and I took so to wrap
it up here for you guys on this message
side you have to understand this part
guys I want to finish with this
never in my life have I been more
optimistic about the future and shit's
never been crazier than it is today
so weird
it has never been crazier than it is
today and I've been I've never been more
optimistic than I am today
the country we're living in living in
has always been known for developing
leaders
if you live in America you come to
America if you attend an event like
driven posted by Albert and sill who
they've been doing this year after year
after year after year after year for six
years Good Times bad times doesn't
matter they're going to put their events
together which by the way Make some
noise for preciatos for doing a great
job hosting this event
this entire event was put together
[Applause]
this entire event
in a greedy way you have to think about
it this way this entire event when I
would come to events I would say this
this entire event's been put together
for one person
I don't care if there's 10 000 people in
the Room 5 000 people in normal thousand
people or 100 people in the room this
entire event was put together for one
person and that's me
which means it's who
it's you you got to receive the message
you got to make that paradigm shift
and then 6 12 24 36 months 10 years 13
years 26 years later
we're going to be reading about your
story I'm going to sit there and say
look at these this guy talked about an
event he was at 2022 when the market was
going crazy he attended this event
called driven look at what this guy did
with his life good for freaking him good
for freaking her good for freaking that
husband and wife that made a decision to
do something big for themselves and then
you're gonna be proud of yourself
[Applause]
foreign